- Welcome, everyone.
We're really excited to
have our fourth and final
Dean's Invited Speaker for this semester.
We'll have more to come.
We'll announce those soon.
And thanks again to Tsai City
for letting us host these here.
It's been a great series for us.
This is one I'm really looking forward to.
Royal Hansen is the VP
for Security at Google.
He was class of '97.
same class as my sister
actually, and also in Saybrook.
So you may know her, Susie Brock.
Do you know if that rings a bell?
- Of course.
I would never have put that together.
- Yeah, so.
- We'll have to talk
about that. That's nice.
- That's my little sister, yeah.
In any case, so we've
just made that connection,
which is interesting.
- Wow, yeah.
- He was a computer science major.
Learned everything he
knows from Mike Fisher here
in the front row about security, so and.
- You can blame him for Google's Foibles,
and that's (Jeffrey laughing).
- So prior to that, he
worked for American Express
as a VP for Information.
- Same kind of technology, security.
- Okay, and at Morgan Stanley.
So we're really excited
to hear from him about
how he's thinking about
security in the sort of new era
of AI systems and how
they're being deployed.
The way that these kind of
call on questions of privacy
and security as we input our information
so that we can get
answers to the questions
we'd like to know the answers to.
Lots of questions needing
to be asked, answered,
and explored with this, you
know, massive scale compute
that's going on at Google.
So we're kind of relieved
to know that a friend,
a child of Yale University is at the helm
of this bold new effort at Google.
And we're really excited to hear from him.
He's gonna give about, you
know, 25, 30 minutes of remarks,
and then we'll open it up for questions.
So you'll have plenty of time to ask
and we will address your
questions after that.
- Great, thanks.
- All right.
Welcome Royal.
- Thanks, Dean.
And it was great,
we saw each other not
even a week ago, is it?
Or maybe it's a little over a week.
It's something like that in California.
I was super impressed with
the collection of Deans.
How many deans did you have there?
- [Jeffrey] All of them.
- It really was all of them, yeah.
(Jeffrey quietly talking)
And I mean, apart from
that just being impressive,
it is one of the reasons
I've wanted to get closer
to the university again and really,
as the computer science
department has sort of expanded,
I mean, that's probably an understatement.
You know, when I graduated,
I know if we ask you had to guess,
there were eight of us in the major.
So it's sort of, it's
like a different era.
I mean, it might as well have
been in the 19th century,
not the 20th.
But to see though
the full university come together
around some of these topics.
I don't, you know, as someone
who wants to participate
in these discussions
and help society work out
a lot of these questions,
I think Yale has an incredibly
important role to play,
and I would like to, you know,
help in that and be a part of it.
So I really do feel like
the meetings we've had
over the last year and even
today with students, professors,
not just in the computer
science department,
I'm super excited for.
So as we, I have maybe 15
slides, sort of relatively quick
and just hopefully set the table.
But as Dean Brock said,
I do privacy, safety, and security,
anything bad that can happen at Google.
And so we could talk about any of that
as you ask questions.
The slides are more about AI
just 'cause I think it's something that's,
it's more topical and
sort of front of mind
for me at the moment.
But happy to go in a
variety of directions.
Let's see, with that,
the rendering across the Google
slides instead of PowerPoint
probably gets that AI in the wrong place.
The first point I'd like to make,
and as we go through the slides,
I think we sometimes forget
that in the security of AI,
so this means think about
like software security,
data protection, cryptography,
that's a whole body of work,
and I'll talk about
that in the second half.
But I've been really impressed
and excited about the uses of
these large language models
in AI more generally in the
service of safety and security.
So I'm just gonna remind
us a little bit of that
in beginning so that in our enthusiasms
to kind of restrict and regulate.
You know, you see lots of, you
saw the White House this week
and lots of efforts, and
it's all good efforts
to come to grips with it.
But we are doing some
incredible things as a society.
You can think of the AlphaFold,
just the most recent
publication this week,
the protein pathways,
like we're going places we've never been.
And I suspect we're really,
really just at the beginning.
And those are in the service
of health, safety, even if not,
you know, and I'll talk
about a few examples
of cybersecurity, but to
me there are two topics.
How do we use this stuff
to make people safer?
And how do we secure
it, make it safe itself?
So I'll cover both of those.
You know, wildfires, just
a few real world examples.
And then we'll get into
the more technical side
that in California in particular,
obviously in Canada this year.
I was in Greece last month
for a democracy forum.
And it tells you kind
of the, I joined Google
because I felt like it was a moment
where people would all
of a sudden wanna talk,
not just about the technical work,
but the implications of it.
So in Athens, we were talking about
the role of democracy in technology.
We went with the government there,
and they're busy in the face
of both floods and fires,
thinking about how they deploy into areas
where there's very little
electricity, little power,
and even internet connectivity.
How do you get very lightweight sensors
so they can detect early
fires and flood conditions
to get ahead of these things?
But it's interesting that like the,
that happened in California,
happening in Greece,
happening all over the world
for climate related activity.
And I think enormous
opportunities to use AI there.
The next one, you know,
obviously we talk about Waymo
or Cruise or these different
examples of self-driving cars,
but the safety benefits
of using large models
in transportation are incredible.
Now my brother-in-law
always tells this story
he was a member of the
American Medical Association
when they convinced the airlines
to let two years and
under children fly on laps
because they didn't wanna do that
cause they were gonna
kill so many children
in accidents in the flights.
And they made the mathematical argument
that you would save children's lives
because they wouldn't fly.
They would drive those
200, 300, 400 mile trips,
and if you just did
the actuarial analysis,
you would kill more children under two
by forcing them to have
a seatbelt on a flight
than by letting them sit
on their parents' lap.
And just give it an example
of where it's that kind of analysis,
I think we're all gonna have to do
as we think about the
application of these technologies
in different arenas.
It doesn't mean that it will
always be the right answer,
but I think you could,
you can make a pretty strong argument
that the safety benefits,
if we look at it with clear eyes,
will be greater in taking
some risk with the technology
than in being conservative.
Again, that's gonna vary,
but I think it's a really good example.
I talked about AlphaFold,
and I'm most excited about
the developments in health
and, you know, computational
biology and the use of AI.
I actually think it's an area where Yale,
I'm sort of really excited
to see where you all go,
given the strength of the
molecular biology program here
and the combination
with the sort of the growth
in the technology side.
I mentioned Deep Mind.
When you go to the Deep
Mind or the AlphaFold paper.
Mind office in London,
they don't put up any of their
technical papers on the wall,
like sort of in the lobby.
They put up only their science papers,
nature, science, health.
They are in this to solve human problems,
not just, you know, it's all tools to them
to get these things done.
And I'm super impressed with that group.
If people have ever heard
Demis Hassabis talk,
who's the CEO, just incredible.
And has become a friend as
all of this has come together,
but I think I'm really inspired
by the work they do in health.
And I actually think
it's probably the area
we'll be most surprised at
the developments using AI.
Just one slight sidebar on
that is that my senior thesis,
we couldn't get David Lerner
to come to this I guess,
but David was my senior thesis advisor
and I've tried to look back in,
you know, my email records are not great
from the yale.edu era,
and I need the Google search of that,
but he had a multidimensional
cluster analysis,
really, I think it's called Diana maybe
or something like that.
But that very early on they had used
to do mammogram kind of detecting
anomalies in mammograms.
This is, you know, this is 90s,
and now we're, you know, really seeing
the sort of progression in that work.
But, you know, way back when,
that's what was going on here,
using neural networks in
their very basic levels.
That's what I started
doing at Yale years ago.
Super excited about that.
I mentioned cybersecurity.
So again, before we even
get into securing AI,
it's worth noting that, so
the example I have on there
is the Play Store.
So there, every day we scan
128 billion app to device pairs
to make sure they're still operating
in a way that, you know,
we get this sort of safety
that no harmful apps found.
And so you get that in
the Android ecosystem.
You can't look at 128
billion apps or app instances
without using some sort of
large modeling capabilities.
And this goes back further
than the large language models.
But we're using, you know, machines.
Humans are not looking at that stuff.
This is all purely done through
the training of classifiers
and looking for anomalies in
behavior of on-device apps.
Real world making people safer,
you know, across the globe
at the billions of people scale.
Gmail, which people would, you know,
I think you probably are
more than familiar with,
and we could take a poll on
whether people are happy or sad
with the spam filters at the moment.
But you know, it's a hard problem
because in cybersecurity we
have the opposite problem
of some of these other areas
where you're aiming for a perfect score.
Every time you get to a perfect score,
and you block all the phishing attacks,
again using these classifiers,
the adversary is sentient and active.
They are looking at it and
changing their approach.
So there's no such thing
as ever getting to 100%.
You get to 100%,
they're immediately gonna
change their approach.
Oftentimes even weaponizing
your defenses against you.
So it's in some ways what makes
the field really, really fun
because it's got, it never ends.
It's another thing that
makes it really difficult
because, you know, I get
beaten up semi-regularly
because we let too much spam
in, in trying to tune this.
So it really is like keeping a ship afloat
to keep it at the right
tolerance for those classifiers
because we're, you know, we're looking at
literally hundreds of billions of messages
over the course of a week.
The last one, which I
don't think most people
probably know about,
and by design, and
probably the best example,
something called Safe Browsing.
So years ago Google realized
we would learn pretty quickly
when a phishing site had been stood up
to be the basis of a email and link
to get someone to enter a password
or download some sort of malware.
You know, then watering
hole attacks start to occur
where you're just
browsing, you're searching,
set up a site to look like
a site you're used to,
and it drops malware on your local device.
We would pick these things up
just for the scope of what
we saw on the internet
and start to build a list
and block those things from ever,
those sites from ever being rendering.
Or in the case where we weren't sure,
but it looked like it might be a problem,
we would give a warning.
We put that behind Chrome,
but that's now behind Safari.
It's behind Firefox, you know,
in some forms it's even
be behind the, you know,
other browsers, and it's
on 4 billion devices.
You know, we're sort of talking
on the order of magnitude
of the number of people on the planet
that have access to the internet.
Every time they go to a site,
whether they know it or not,
it's being checked
against these known lists.
You know, and we start to offer things
that allow the time between detection
and usage in the browser
to even go down to under 30 minutes.
So all of that using sort of the
what you'd call old
school machine learning.
This is not necessarily
the large language models,
but this is what we've
been doing for many years
to solve these kinds of problems at scale.
So that's using AI to
keep people safe broadly,
physically as well as in
the cybersecurity world.
The next sets of slides are about
how do you make this
newfangled AI infrastructure,
whether it's GPUs and TPUs,
whether it's foundational models
or frontier models that then
are distilled and deployed
into all these other form
factors, chat bots and otherwise,
how do you make that secure by default?
One of the things I love about Google
is we early on decided
we didn't want to put
too many bells and whistles on the front
like that safe browsing.
But you're better off as a user
if you never have to
worry about the security.
If we force you to deploy
another piece of software
and configure it, we're likely to fail
because people are not gonna do it.
They're not gonna do it well.
So how do we make this AI
infrastructure secure by default?
And just to give you a taste for the,
kinda the problems that we're up against,
I talked about the biological sciences.
Just to give, we were at
Stanford, I guess I can say that.
I don't know what the rivalries
are these days on these,
but you know, but in the
spirit of an academic activity
with the computer science department
and the biology department,
and you know, you see these
four base pair primitives
for DNA, just to give it to
the hook to talk about this,
increasingly the 3D printing world
through model organisms if
you wanna think about that,
whether yeast or others,
you can give a computer the instructions,
the DNA to RNA and then protein pathway,
just like AlphaFold,
instructions to create
life in various forms.
In fact, the story they told
was, these are sort of the,
this is Switzerland, Italy,
France in the case of COVID.
So if you think back to sort
of the very earliest months
of '20, this is that, that
says march right here.
And you see that in Italy it was first,
but it, COVID-19 was
transmitted from China
over the internet in its DNA instructions
to the WHO in Switzerland
and then printed and existed
in Switzerland in that area
over 10 days before it arrived
via human transmission.
So when I talk about doing security,
I don't mean it's just
for email or websites.
We're headed to a world
where the structures of life
and society are digitized,
and then the whole supply
chain needs to be safe.
Cause the mistakes here are very different
than in one where your email,
I miss a spam message.
So it kind of gives you a
sense of where we're headed,
and AI being a really big part of that.
One other idea that we've
talked a little bit about,
and I think again is a good
one for the context of Yale is,
let's just start with
the big picture question,
and then explain it.
What is a country on the internet?
So much of the discussions
that I get involved in are,
well, does the data
resident in the country?
Can the government have
access to this data?
Who, which jurisdiction
has sort of sovereignty
over this question?
And it doesn't really map
to the technical world.
You all know this very well.
We've spent the last 50 years
trying to distribute data
and computational power
everywhere it needs to be.
We didn't, it's not really grounded
in the geography of a map.
The example that I sometimes talk about,
there's a professor at Claremont
who wrote his dissertation
on the inception
or the sort of the development
of cartographic technology
in the 15th and 16th century
and the establishment of the nation state.
There's, you know, historically
we thought of France
and England and these sort
of European nation states
coming into form because
of Hobbes and Locke
and these kind of sort of
theory of how to run a state.
He makes the case
that actually you couldn't have France
Before you could build a very
specific map and replicate it
and distribute it
so that you could even talk
about the thing France.
Just, it's an interesting question,
this sort of intersection
between the material conditions
or the technology developments
and the political and societal
structures that go with it.
My question and I think one we
should work on as a community
is what is the nation state?
I get in these weird
discussions with people
about the location of our data center,
and people have religious
discussions about this.
I get the spirit of it,
but that's just not the way the internet
and applications and software work.
You want these things to
have interconnectivity.
People are not gonna go to the
data center with a forklift
and get the rack and take it away
and then use forensics
software to get the data.
There are much more normal ways
to get at that data if
you wanted to do it.
So I think this discussion
of what is a country
in an era of the internet
is super interesting
and related to then
how we solve questions,
questions of security, privacy, safety.
Because you know, you're gonna have legal
and regulatory, other
activity on top of that.
The other example related to that,
just against some images
that'll recall it,
is I was in Paris, don't tell Lem this,
my friend in the political
science department,
talking about a new
cybersecurity related law.
And one of the ministers
said to me, you know,
we are Latin in our sort of history
like so the Latin Roman tradition of law,
and we're addicted to writing laws.
Like we really like it,
which is great, and you know,
so you get to how people sort
of go after their governance
and things.
But I said, what will happen
when the laws we continue
to write are now expressed
or written or mapped to COBOL,
and we're 50 years down the road
and someone needs to change that law.
You're not gonna be able
to pull it off the shelf
and edit it and publish it
back and have people obey it.
Somebody's gonna have to
know how to change the COBOL.
I just use that as sort
of an antiquated version.
People even know what COBOL
is here anymore? Okay, good.
Maybe I should use something,
another example for the,
depending on the crowd.
Fortran, I don't know what the,
my prologue interpreter written in LISP.
What was the, that was
my favorite project,
my favorite problem set with,
I can't remember who had us do that,
but really you in
technology, we in technology
will be coding the laws
of today and tomorrow,
and then changing them will
be a availability risk.
Things will break.
Let alone will they,
will the spirit of the law
actually meet the spirit
of the regulation.
So again, in all these areas of AI,
or I mean AI is gonna make
this even more complicated,
but it just, it happens today
in the context of software.
And just to maybe bring that
a little bit closer to home.
I was in, I've spent a
lot of time in Poland
over the last 18 months after
the invasion of Ukraine.
And you know, we've gotten
to know the cybersecurity community
in eastern and central Europe really well
because it's, I mean, the truth is
that the attacks on
Ukrainian infrastructure
go back to 2014,
and the Wiper and many of the
kind of destructive malware
you've seen are a result of
attacks on Ukraine from Russia
and threat actors back at 2016 and beyond.
The latest developments though
that when I was last in Poland
with the cyber command group
there, you now have weapons.
We saw what was, I think the
Dutch just announced something
about a aircraft that's being, you know,
that's being delivered.
But they pointed out to
us that the supply chain
for ships, trucks, warehouses,
for all these weapons
or supplies that are ultimately
flowing through Poland
and into Ukraine are the,
that's the underbelly of
the cybersecurity issue
because Russian threat actors track that.
If they can figure out
which device, which weapon,
which supply is going where,
when, strategic advantage,
not just in the battlefield,
but in sort of the broader context of war.
And that's got nothing to do
with the military or the government.
These are like mom and pop warehouses
and trucking companies who
know nothing about Google
or Morgan Stanley's
level of cybersecurity.
These people are as vulnerable
as anyone on the planet to these attacks.
I say all of those things then to say
we are working on this framework
called the Secure AI Framework.
And just the spirit of
it is to not throw out
in this new rush to AI
all of the improvements
and foundational security work
that we've built up over
the last couple decades.
Think of supply chains, think
of kind of the full stack
of a piece of software.
I'm not gonna drain it here
because it's more of a framework,
but the idea is that
the way we handle data,
the way we write, you know,
the logic, the business logic
of a piece of software, the
way the input is validated,
think in the context of AI,
historically for a website,
you would validate the
entry that a user put in
before you passed it
along to the database.
People have heard of
things like SQL injection
or sort of where the code
is passed to the database,
and if not checked, can extract more data
than you would think.
Sort of simple approach to it.
But in the world of the
large language model,
there's no intermediation of the language
because the language is the code.
The model interacts with the
English that the user types in.
So your ability to constrain
that or to check it
is dramatically changed from
where you've got JavaScript
or something on the server side.
So all of a sudden we've got
a whole new class of ways
of trying to solve this input
validation or data lineage.
Think of the other thing that,
how do we know which data
is being used in training?
How do we know where the data goes
that's entered into the models?
That's what this is designed to do
is to take the best of the last 20 years
and make sure in the flurry of activity,
we don't forget all these
foundational things,
things we learned in the
cryptography courses.
We don't throw those out
just because, you know,
you do have this risk
every time there's a
massive innovative moment
that people build it
from scratch very quickly
to get to market, and they forget about
all the work we've done over
the years to, on security.
So I hope that's at least a table setting.
And I think the key for me is that,
and the reason I came to Google was
I could never solve the
problems we're talking about
or participate at one bank or
one, you know, institution.
You had to be part of
this fabric of technology,
whether it was data centers and cloud,
whether it's mobile
devices, whether it's email
and video rendering.
I think that we're at a unique moment
where the infrastructure
for the 21st century
is being laid down.
If we mess it up now,
it'll be like the railroads
of a previous era and
you won't change those,
the gauge of the railways again.
So we'll live with
whatever infrastructure,
security we build right now for AI.
I'd love to answer questions.
That'd be great.
Thanks.
(audience applauding)
- I'm sort of fascinated by
the framing you give, Royal,
about the need for a
certain level of scale,
and I think, you know,
we wrestle with this
in universities as we
do strategic planning
and think about how we can, you know,
we're not gonna be in the
business of competing on scale
with Google, but we do want
to feel like we're part
of a conversation that involves leadership
where the scale exists.
What do you see the right kind of way
for universities to engage
with these questions,
which clearly are affecting
and asking questions
that leaders in academia
should be thinking about?
- Yeah, I mean the good
news is I think on work
like the data centers, networks, AI,
kind of at the foundational levels,
there's actually a really rich exchange
between academia and these tech companies.
I think the problem or the question
or really for the next step
is that's been siloed on our side
and somewhat siloed I
think in the academy.
And so finding concrete,
and you told me this, I
think the first time we met,
which I think was, it helped
me frame some of my thinking.
It's one thing to talk in the abstract,
it's another thing to have a joint project
on a particular question, a
legal or regulatory question.
The good news is the Googles of the world
are now much more in the
middle of those legal
and regulatory questions,
whether we like it or not.
So now we're I think more open than,
you know, I don't think 10, 15 years ago
it would've been even
interesting or relevant
to some of these companies
to be in those discussions.
I think it is now.
How do we bring the other
departments around the university
to the table in concrete enough ways?
It struck me, we talked about this before,
like as the Deans were
all around that room,
just have to have one
conversation in that room,
but could it become 15 conversations
about regulation, healthcare,
you know, different areas.
So I would, I think you can help us
by convening that cross-disciplinary work
in ways that we would
never even know how to.
- Yeah, I'm looking forward to that.
So first of all, and
I think second of all,
it is interesting how
we are already seeing
kind of calls on computer science
and on the technical side from engineering
from the other schools.
You know, we need not
just to apply algorithms
to say medical data or problems like this,
but to really understand mechanistically
how these things are working
and how they're processing information.
So I think that's a key point.
The other thing though that
sometimes we hear internally
to engineering is, well, you
know, we saw neural networks,
and then there was a long winter,
and then there was a little
sort of data science blip,
and then there was another long winter,
and this is just gonna
be another hype cycle,
and there'll be another long AI winter.
Do you see that as?
- That's a great question
because I, you know,
I've seen a number of those along the way.
I, you know, just personally
and the more I work with the
Deep Mind folks and others
in the kind of work we're talking about,
whether it's for the malware analysis
or safety filtering on the internet,
people I really respect
that are not into this
for the investment side,
'cause I think that, you know,
that's sort of a,
it's helpful but not
always the right signal,
are surprised at what this is able to do
in ways that I think
make me feel like we are,
there's still a lot to go here.
And just my thinking on it,
just for what it's worth
and talking about it
is that the big difference is gonna be
can these large models or
the next layer up from them
become the equivalent
of the operating system?
Instead of you going, you know,
all these problems I talked about before,
you go and solve one use case at a time,
and you train data,
and you tune the data,
and then you put it at a
particular point in the logic
of the code to make a decision.
I'm starting to see instances
where the user themselves
in interacting with that next
layer of, you know, model,
tune the model as they use it,
and so you, that'll be far more effective
and efficient in writing software
than having a software developer
in the middle of that activity.
If we can do that, I think you,
that is a very different world
than one of a bunch of
Linux boxes strung together
running some middleware.
- [Jeffrey] Right, right.
- And I think that's, that's
what people are working on.
- Yeah, that, I mean I think
that's one of the things we
heard when we were out west
is that this,
this changes the way anyone
can interact with a computer.
Whether it's someone
who wants to write a
technical piece of code
or someone who just kind
of wants to take an idea
and turn it into something that
can be deployed technically.
- I mean the interesting,
and I'm really enjoying this,
I talk about my, you know,
back to the neural network
with Professor Lerner was that
you know, so much of the work historically
went into training, you
know, or into labeling data.
Obviously the deep
learning quickly allowed us
to label, auto label data
and train these models.
But what I didn't realize is
this reinforcement learning
with human feedback
and different versions of that, you know,
if you can get an expert
to react to the output
of one of these models,
you can immediately use that feedback
and the model gets exponentially better,
not just a little bit better.
And so all of a sudden the user
becomes the most valuable
piece of the equation.
It's why I'm actually not
worried about the labor questions
in many ways.
I actually think people
are gonna find this
remarkably democratic and democratizing
'cause they're gonna be able to do things
they were never able to,
and they in fact will add what they know
that nobody else knew.
And the model will get that
much better that quickly.
But that's not the way we write software,
and that's what,
that's the work that's gotta be done.
- Right.
- Because you can't just say, okay,
let's use it like an operating system.
That isn't, like that's not works.
- Interesting.
We were talking a little bit earlier about
how as products of
Yale, you have a kind of
a latent humanism that is
kind of baked into your brain
regardless of what you end up doing.
What, you know, as we
think about strategically
what makes the most sense
for us to be doubling down on here,
how do you see your own experience at Yale
as informing your work on the one hand?
And two, do you think we have
kind of a privileged position
or you know, strategic advantage
in terms of bringing these broad
strengths of the university
across the humanities, arts, law, policy,
et cetera to this discussion?
- I definitely think you do.
And that's something I
would like to be a part of
and hope, you know, I can
help in any small way.
But I think, and again
going back to what you said,
and this we need to spend more time,
on the concrete activity
between departments.
I think we'll have lots of
great discussion, right?
The beauty of this place, it could convene
and you can do things
like this and many others,
but to make it concrete
and progress the discussion
and then, Ruzica, I think
we met with this morning
who's great.
Yeah, we sort of couldn't stop.
- She's fabulous,
- She's great,
but we really sort of mind melded
on this idea of abstraction layers.
And so I spend a lot of my time at Google
trying to convince these
engineers that it's, you know,
in the early days of Google,
if you dealt with an abstraction
layer, you were a loser
cause you couldn't code.
Like you had to talk about
these things like you were,
like this and Jeff's
probably the patron saint
of that stuff, right?
Like these people were hands on
in ways that was just not true.
But we've gotten to a
point where I would argue
you can't embed all those laws in code.
You can't.
- Right.
- That becomes a weakness
if you can't abstract and interact,
I mean APIs being this sort of,
web services being some instances,
but I think we need to
take it even further
in the abstraction.
And that was the point.
So I think the law school, the health,
like can we come up with a vocabulary
that matches the abstraction layer
that is concretely mapped to technology
and to policy, law,
scientific, you know, laws.
To me that's the work that has to be done.
And so instead of just talking about it,
can we pick these domains
and say we're gonna,
and that's why I like the SAFE Framework.
It says like find a,
each of these domains
is gonna need a technical
abstraction layer
that they can reliably do their work on
and still have it map to the
technical implementation.
Right now that happens
through your software developer somewhere
or some other company.
So there's almost like
a vocabulary, I mean,
which I think the
academy's good at, right?
- Right.
- Like this is the whole scientific,
you're sort of genus and species.
That's what we're talking about.
- And I mean we've had a
couple of conversations
with AI folks about what this is revealing
about the structure and
indeterminacy of language itself,
you know, almost from a
mathematical perspective.
Not that we haven't been
studying language mathematically
for many years, but the
mathematical questions
become part of how the algorithms work.
I mean in terms of how you
do search through language
and how you represent language.
- Totally.
- All of these things
you're talking about.
- I mean one just quick example of that
that sort of, I mean, makes
sense but surprised me
was that if you train
a model on just text,
sort of one mode,
and you train even with a smaller amount
of the image and text,
that second model is better at text only
because to your point, our
ideas and what we understand
are not perfectly abstracted to language.
- [Jeffrey] Right.
- And in fact it learns something
that we don't express directly.
It's loss-y right.
Language to ideas loses information.
- Right.
I have, I'm sorry, I just
have one more question
I have to ask him, and
then I'll open it up.
So on this point, kind of
the way that that tech,
that images can improve the
way language interpreters
or language models work, do
you see projecting forward
a future where in some sense
by say representing by ingesting video
and having this be part of the language,
which I know we're already doing,
but that there's an opportunity
to explore how these models actually learn
like something like physics?
Like watching balls bounce
and things like this.
I mean, is that,
is that something you're
thinking about at Google?
- Yeah, you know, and this
would be, now you're getting,
you know, beyond my primary experience,
but what in my world version of that,
the modality, I think
we need to think about
what a modality is.
- [Jeffrey] Right, right.
- Just 'cause you can write it in English,
think of that like a ladder.
All of these things will ride
on the language and image.
Then they need the modality of the arena.
You know, in my case logs.
Like we're gonna train
these large language models
with an additional modality of logs.
Cause logs are, yes, they're text,
but they're not language.
- [Jeffrey] Right, right.
- And I think for each of those domains,
there will be a refining modality,
which maybe it's dimensionality,
and it may be some geometric modality
that needs to be introduced.
But the thing about it is it's not,
don't think of those as separate.
Back to the operating system.
Language I think is a fantastic,
language and visual are
fantastic foundational models
that mean you don't have to,
you're not starting from scratch
in something like physics or biology.
- [Jeffrey] Right, right.
- You can still use whatever's baked in
to the understanding of language.
- So I mean, the fact that we're even able
to have a conversation
as bizarre as this one,
I think represents a turning
point in the evolution
and history of these technologies.
But I wanna open it up to the audience
who took time out of
their day to come here.
Yes, right here.
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
- Oh, we have a microphone actually,
which would be great for the video.
- [Audience Member] So
I got maybe a little bit
of a boring question.
You probably get this a
lot, but you're, you know,
you're involved with security at Google,
dealing with AI risk.
How big do you think existential
risk of AI really is?
How should Google be taking
steps to sort of, you know,
prevent that from getting out of hand?
How are you thinking about that?
And then also, you know,
in computer science
there's often this dialectic
between like making something open source
and making it secure,
and that's why everyone like, you know,
loved blockchain for the
time that we had it, right?
Where it really seemed
to be very promising.
So how do you ensure that when
you're securing everything
and making AI secure to
prevent that existential risk,
you're not also preventing
small players in the marketplace
from actually being able
to do cool stuff with AI
and kind of drawing a moat
around, you know, meta Google
and Microsoft and Open AI.
- Right.
I may need a disclaimer
before I answer some of these questions.
Huh, yeah, nothing going on in the world
on that front at the moment.
Let's see, let's see.
The first one was on, sorry, I lost the,
as you got started about antitrust,
I got thinking about that, sorry.
Existential risk, yeah.
So again, I have not spent my life
like some of the folks in the AI research,
and I think we should respect
and do think about alignment
in these questions.
But from a practical
perspective in this security,
the thing that gives me some comfort
and sort of there's a
downside to it as well
is most of the world is
not automated very well.
I mean, think about how
much of the world you still,
you know, the technology stops well short
of full automation,
and that's gonna, that means
that like even the best
ML model in the world
knows how to kill
everyone, whatever that is.
It's not gonna be able to do it
because the things aren't automated.
So we're gonna have to,
like we still got a lot
of work in the world
to automate even the very basic things.
You can all imagine things
that you could do much more automated
with your phone or things.
So I think we've got a long
ways to go in not the ML work,
just continuing to instrument
and automate everything,
you know, the world we live in.
You know, if you lived in
a perfectly automated world
where everything you thought
could be done, you know,
then I think you, then
you begin to have those.
We've got a lot of work.
I mean, as someone who lives,
you know, 30, you know,
we got 180,000 people at Google,
and, you know, it's remarkably slow
how much is still not
automated, even in our world.
So I think, I mean, I
don't say that with pride.
I just think it's a
reality of where we're at.
It's not just, the model is not on its own
able to automate things
that are not automated.
Someone's gonna have to do that.
And I think it's a good, you know,
it's a good example of
where the practitioner,
somebody said it like, the
map is not the territory
if that makes sense.
A person can know the map,
the model can know the map perfectly.
That doesn't mean they can
manipulate the territory.
On the second question,
you know, I don't know.
It's a good question on
where open source models,
closed source, frontier
and foundational models
versus distilled.
Again, my only thing would be to say,
I think over time these
foundational models
will be more like operating systems,
and people will ride on them,
whatever form of getting there,
whether open source or not.
I think the constraints
in many ways are more just
the work it goes into
building those frontier
and foundational models,
whether, you know,
whether the open source or
not. But I'm not, this is not,
I don't know enough about the
domain specifically to be,
I'm just charged with securing
it if like, if it goes wrong.
- [Jeffrey] Great, another
question, over here?
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
I was just curious,
with all of these new
frameworks coming out
from different companies and governments,
they have a lot of different
pillars, learning from history.
I'm curious what you think
are the largest areas
that they're missing
or that they're not
putting enough emphasis on
or any shortcomings that you see
in these new pillars of safety and ethics?
- Yeah, I think the two hardest areas,
it's not because people aren't saying it,
but are the data questions
and then the interface, the user input.
I don't think that
people are missing that.
I just think there's still
work to be done to codify
and commoditize the controls.
So everybody can do that.
But I'm not, maybe back to the question,
I think maybe the people
are over-indexing at times
to the third, the other question,
the kind of larger risks.
I'm pretty focused here on the plumbing.
Like how do we make this
thing stable, solid,
reliable, repeatable for everybody?
And so maybe to the degree
that people are distracted
by some of the longer term risks
from the short term, that's
what I'm worried about.
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
- [Jeffrey] Other questions?
Yeah?
- [Audience Member] So you said AI
has been using very like different fields
including the economics
and also like the technologies.
But how about the fields
that has relatively
low tolerance of error,
for example, the healthcare
and the autonomous vehicles.
What do you think, how reliable
and how secure is in those fields?
- That's a great question.
You know, the hallucination
is one thing in a chat bot.
It's a totally different
thing in a healthcare device.
Is that the, you know, the
spirit of the question?
I think, look a little
like quantum computing,
the same thing.
Most of the work,
and it's even back to
this question of risks
of input and output,
I think we've got more work to do
to make those safe in more
and more sensitive worlds.
But that's the work that's going on.
Just like in quantum computing,
the real question is
can you make error correction efficient?
I think the same thing
is gonna go on here.
How far down can we drive the error bars
on those hallucinations
in different arenas?
But the good news is, this
is back to my point of like,
if you ride on a foundational model
and then you keep distilling it,
it actually is, you know,
chess is the simple example,
but Alpha, I think it's already proving
that it can do these
things very, very well
if you constrain it enough.
And the question is, can
you relax the constraints
and get the precision you need?
That's the front line of
the work right now for sure.
- [Jeffrey] Yeah, right here.
Go ahead.
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
So in terms of regulation and security
with newly developed AI models,
and you mentioned that you think
that the user experience is
integrated within the software.
What's your approach with regulating
or your conceptual
approach with regulating it
in terms of like starting broad
and then specifying it down to case models
when my experience and my use of an AI
may be different than someone else's?
Do you start broad?
Do you start with more specific instances
and then connect those to
like a broader umbrella?
Or is there a specific path
that you would think would
be optimal for taking?
- It's a good, you know,
it's a good question in a couple of ways.
One, my first answer is,
and this is informed from
living in banks for a while.
I think it's important
not to sort of over,
make cybersecurity or AI overly precious,
and to remember that these things are done
in the service of a particular domain.
You know, financial services,
transportation, healthcare.
And what we really wanna regulate
is the outcomes in that domain.
The problem is that, you know,
and this happened in cybersecurity to us
that everybody rushes
to the newfangled area
and wants to regulate it
as a class onto itself.
I think the mature state will become
healthcare will use AI in
lots of interesting ways.
And there will be regulation
that is specific to healthcare.
I think it's tricky to
imagine all the implications
or knock-on effects of AI writ large
with enough precision to
be a helpful guardrail.
That doesn't mean that,
I think what's useful now
is lots of people at the table
learning and getting better,
but my hope would be that
they become industry specific,
and they're agnostic to AI.
What we care about is outcomes and risks.
Because the thing's
gonna change so quickly,
I don't think, I think
we always get in trouble
when we over specify
regulatory action to technology
that changes faster and faster every year.
The other one though that,
I think this is back
to the the university,
but there's a whole, I mean,
political theory is all about this stuff.
Like how do you regulate well?
It scares me that when the tech,
like I don't want just the
tech industry doing this.
I want good, thoughtful regulation.
I don't want reactive
regulation as a weapon.
I want it as a collaboration
for healthy innovation and outcomes.
So I think the university, you know,
instead of this being tech
against somebody else,
how do we together write good regulation
that promotes the level of
innovation and competition?
Like that's the right thing.
You know, you've seen lots of these,
what was the video recently
about the telecom industry?
Like we're pretty good at doing
regulation bad in many ways.
It's the whole concept
of regulated capture
and all this stuff.
So how do we do it better?
I don't know that we are the,
we do not have the corner
on on that question.
- Can you speak just for a
second about how this intersects
issues of intellectual property
when you're training on, you
know, vast amounts of data,
some of which may or may not be owned
and then reproduced,
and, you know, that's
a regulatory question,
but it's also just a, it's
a technological question
in terms of what the
mashup is that is spat out
by the algorithm of PM.
- It's a great topic that will
be more than just technical.
And I think that's the, like,
so on the technical side,
lots of work going into data lineage
and which data is used, even at scale.
And then the other side,
which is as it's produced,
you know, how do you water
market or identify it.
But as you all know with
like certificate authorities
and websites, it's like
the least interesting thing
about the internet.
And I worry that, you know, I
think what we need is societal
and legal norms that go with that.
The technical implementation
is not gonna be
either the answer or the impediment.
And I think we're gonna need new norms
of when you modify someone else's,
not even the technical platform,
but you modify someone else's material.
How's that gonna work?
- [Jeffrey] Right.
- How will licensing work?
So I think all of that, back
to the question of regulation
has to be a whole of society question.
I think we get in trouble
when, you know, we as engineers
or we as society think there's
one answer to these things,
and we've just not found
the mathematical equation.
These are actually ongoing processes
that need feedback loops and
healthy, legitimate outcomes
that people respect
'cause they'll evolve.
- [Jeffrey] Yeah, where
there a question over here?
- [Audience Member] So I
kind of wanna return back
to the idea of like regulation
under industry verticals.
So something that I'm really interested in
is that like it seems really
easy for all these companies
to talk about like these big lofty ideas
of like we need to be regulated.
But when it comes down
to the actual language
of like what these regulations are,
it becomes really tricky.
And like the specific
instance that I'm thinking of
is like when Sam Altman
testified in front of Congress
and then like saying that
we need more regulation,
but then a couple days later
the EU came out with a package
and OpenAI just completely rejected it.
So do you have any like ideas in mind
to like how to resolve this
kind of issue that we see?
- Yeah, and I, again, back
to my banking history,
I think we need to get to a place
where there's a healthy and
informed ongoing refinement
of the approach.
And so to your point, I
think there's, you know,
this is new, and people
are posturing a bit
in all kinds of ways,
but what we want is industry,
government, this public sector
in whatever form
iterating towards something that works.
I guess my point is I don't
think there's a single group
within that who knows enough
to write the perfect regulation
even if it existed.
And so what we need is a
healthy way, to your point,
you know, we need a healthy
way to have the dialogue,
not to sort of reject things out of hand,
but to refine them as we go.
Because look, I just said, we talk about,
I don't know what it'll
look like in a couple years
talking about a large, a frontier model.
Will that be, like that's a concept,
but is it well-defined enough
to be the basis of a regulation?
That's a good question.
And so I think we need to use
that. We need a vocabulary,
and it's partly why I go
back to the domain specific,
because again, when we operate
in these really high level abstractions,
I'm not sure that it's even
implementable in some cases,
let alone, you know, to
people's reactions to it.
Whereas you can look at
outcomes in a domain,
even if the tech changes under the hood.
- All right, I think we have time
for maybe one more,
and if there're none, I have one,
and you knew it was coming.
Right here?
- [Audience Member] Yes, thank
you, Royal, your analogy,
- Oh, we need a mic for you, I guess.
I can hear you, but yep.
- [Audience Member] I enjoyed
your analogy with cartography,
the definition of a country,
and it made me think of
digital and data sovereignty.
- Yeah.
- [Audience Member] Is it correct to think
that it's not too late to
define a sovereign nation
with respect to data and digital,
and if so, what criteria
would you, can you think of,
what major high level
criteria would you focus on?
- You know, back to the crypto discussion,
we'll come back to my education here,
but we have built just as one example
of an attempt on this,
what we call a sovereign cloud offering
where instead of it
being, you know, we do,
you can do it in various locations,
but we use crypto to define the scope.
And so the cryptography defines
the sovereignty completely.
Really it's geographically
meaningless really,
but it gives the basis for discussion
of this, the scope of the data.
And I think you still
have questions though
of what data,
is any data about me because
I'm an American, American data?
You know, I think there's
lots of use cases,
but at least if somebody can say,
this is what we wanna consider
the data of that country,
I think cryptographic work
provides one possibility
for how to answer that.
The problem is, the practicality is
no data lives on its own.
I mean very little.
It needs to interact with other data.
And so if you're using crypto to do it,
you need some key exchange or
some means of combining data,
and all of a sudden you
make people manage keys,
and people stink at that.
So yes, there's some offerings,
and I think crypto provides it.
I don't think that's the
long-term answer though.
I think we've gotta come up with
more durable conceptual
models of what the country,
its people, its companies,
its technical infrastructure.
But I think that's work
I'd love to be doing.
I mean, I honestly think that's a question
that the university should
begin to have a thesis about,
not necessarily Google.
- [Jeffrey] Yeah, So last question.
- So I think
- Michael has one?
We gotta give Michael the mic.
- Yes.
- [Michael] Okay.
- Turn it on.
It's on, okay, fine, great.
- So I just wanted to
say that it's very easy
for technologists to think about,
we have to reach out
into these other areas
and incorporate law and medicine
and political science into our thinking
and into our technologies.
But I think you made a good point
that it's the players in those fields
that are going to be
determining our future.
And my question is
can you give any advice to universities
about how we can best get
the technological foundations
out to the people
that are going to be
making these decisions?
In other words, what should we be doing
to help our related colleagues
better understand the
technology and where it's going
and how it's going to affect them?
- It's a great question,
and I think the tension is,
I mean, I think the best way,
and we come back to I
will keep doing this,
is concrete questions that
we can work on together.
Because I think you learn then,
not just the theory of it,
but the practice.
And I think that's what is required
to really learn and to
develop that abstraction
and language that we can then use
for the next instance
and the next instance.
So I think concrete work
where we answer questions
like what's a country on the internet?
And then we force each other to learn,
well, what do you mean, a data center?
Like at some level people don't
really understand what that
or how caching works, right?
And I think you get into
these sort of concepts,
concrete things.
The one thing I would say,
and this is one thing I love about Yale,
I do worry sometimes if the
over enthusiasm for data,
so one way this all happens
is everybody gets excited
about data, right?
All these fields are now quantitative
in ways that seem
ridiculous to me somewhat.
But, so I think that the key is not to be,
not to think of data as,
data is a way to communicate.
It is not the ideas in and of itself.
So I think one of the
things the university
has to continue to offer is to remind us
that these ideas are longer standing
and these concepts go back much further.
The data is a way to have a conversation.
It is not the answer. It
does not solve the conflict.
It does not solve the
partisanship in and of itself.
So that's my,
I guess my one back and
forth on the advice is,
yeah, let's work on things.
Sometimes that means people get data,
and they work together.
I worry that sometimes that, you know,
stops people from digging in
at the real roots of these problems.
- Yeah, well, I wanna thank
Royal again for joining us
and enlightening us.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you.
- One of the things I loved about his talk
and about this conversation
is it kind of reaffirms,
I think, a belief that we share here
that there's work going on in the world
and technology companies
and lots of different places
that should be in deep conversation
with what we're doing here in academia.
The research we're doing,
the teaching we're doing,
that walling ourselves
off from these advances
does us and society no good.
So I'm thrilled that there
seems to be mutual enthusiasm
for continuing this conversation,
and I wanna thank you all
for joining us here today.
So more next semester.
Thanks again.
- Thank you.
(audience applauding)
(soothing tones)